[Music]
yes well container park really is a
prime
example of the unique vision that tony
shea had to revitalize downtown las
vegas
here locals and visitors can come
together to celebrate community
the arts and small businesses now
container park
is the product of shea and the downtown
project which he founded
in 2012. shea invested 350 million
dollars in real estate
entertainment and tech startups in the
area he was crucial in developing
container park and some of the famous
art installations
like the fire breathing praying mantis
today container park celebrated small
business saturday
in the hopes of supporting local
business owners the general manager here
tells me
that shea laid the foundation for what
container park is today
he was a huge visionary a huge part of
container park and all the small
businesses up and coming here in the
area
he also gave people i guess
that room to dream right to be an
entrepreneur and do huge things he's
going to be greatly missed today's
bittersweet
but we're going to we're going to move
on and and continue and
carry what his dream was
and that dream continues this month dtp
companies
which now helps in the development of
downtown las vegas revealed the latest
mural and beautification project in this
area
it's part of a continued effort to
increase walkability in downtown
and to promote the talent of the local
art community here
through his work shea has helped support
thousands of jobs and hundreds
of businesses here in downtown las vegas
and his legacy will continue
through these efforts to revitalize the
downtown las vegas community
reporting live tonight from container
park kate houston 8 news now